When we look at the night sky,
we see a vast cosmos
filled with stars and galaxies and dust,
a cosmos teeming with luminous phenomena.
So we've all heard some version
of that famous Carl Sagan line,
"We are made of star stuff."
And it's true, we are.
And that makes it easy to believe
that what matters is what's visible --
us, the trees, the stars --
because it helps us feel connected
to everything that we can see.
Today, we know that everything
visible in the universe
is composed from a basic set
of building blocks
known as elementary particles.
We call this incredibly elegant picture
the standard model of particle physics,
and we understand it
in great mathematical detail.
Comprehending the standard model
is an enormous achievement.
But we are now certain that it describes
very little of what's out there.
It turns out that most of the stuff
which fills our universe
is completely invisible to us.
In other words, visible matter,
the kind that we
and the stars are made from,
the kind that radiates light,
is not what's normal.
And we, the luminous matter,
we are the cosmic weirdos.
So how do we know?
Well, consider this invisible
nonbinary person,
who's hiding in plain sight
inside of their suit.
We can't exactly see a person,
but we know that they're there,
because the suit is filled out.
So the presence of the invisible enby
is governing how the suit
hangs in space-time.
So we can see a similar effect
with visible matter.
We can see that stars
and galaxies are affected
by the presence of something more,
something completely invisible to us.
So we now know that the universe
is more queer and fantastical
than it looks to the naked eye.
(Cheers)
(Laughter)
That's right.
(Laughter and applause)
So how did the universe get this way,
and what exactly is inside?
So I'm a theoretical physicist
with expertise in particle cosmology.
And it's my job to use math
to study the origin
and evolution of space-time
and every single thing
that's inside of it.
I connect the very small --
elementary particles --
with the extremely large --
galaxies and galaxy clusters,
and I'm a griot of the universe.
I develop creative mathematical narratives
that may just be our cosmic origin story.
Now as a theoretical physicist,
I really love doing math
and coming up with different ideas
that may describe
our mostly invisible universe.
But it's important
to be accountable to data too,
the real stuff.
So after mathematics,
my second favorite tool for addressing
these large cosmological questions
is the biggest laboratory we know,
the universe itself.
Observatories with capabilities
from visible light
to high-energy X-ray and gamma-ray photons
are still some of the best
ways to gain insight
into what's going on in space-time,
with the invisible stuff.
So what you're looking at here
is the Vera C. Rubin Observatory,
an exciting new facility
that's about to see its first light
over the next two years.
It's a leading example
of a new generation of telescopes
that are going to change the way
we see this mostly invisible universe.
Now it's also the case
that swarms of satellites
threaten images from ground-based
facilities like this one.
But the Vera C. Rubin Observatory
can help us understand
where the invisible stuff is
and what it's doing,
which will help us determine
what exactly it is.
So when it comes to the cosmic accounting,
here is what we know so far.
We're in the midst
of a great cosmic drama,
where space-time is curved
and it’s expanding.
And the history and future
of that curvature and expansion
is determined by what's inside,
which is mostly
not visible stuff like us --
that's only about five percent.
The majority of the energy-matter
content in the universe
is something that we call dark energy.
So empty space seems to have
an energy associated with it.
And that's increasingly affecting
how space-time expands.
After dark energy,
the second-largest ingredient
is something that we call dark matter.
So here's the funky thing
about dark matter.
Unlike dark energy,
it gravitates exactly like visible matter.
But it's completely unlike us
in every other way.
So you might be thinking,
"OK, dark matter.
It clearly has a color
associated with it."
It's dark, like my pants.
Right?
But the first thing you should know
about dark matter
is that it doesn't have a color,
and at least at first approximation,
light seems to go right through it,
so we can't see it.
It's invisible, maybe
transparent, maybe clear.
So if you put out your hands
and think about the weight of having
a clump of dark matter in your hands --
that's how it would feel,
but your hands would look
exactly the same.
Today, we believe
that 80 percent of the normally
gravitating matter in the universe
is dark matter.
Dark matter is dominant
on the outskirts of galaxies,
and it affects
stellar motions on the edges.
This effect is actually
how Vera C. Rubin and Kent Ford
found the first substantive evidence
for the existence of dark matter.
What you're looking at here
is an artist's rendering
of our own galaxy, the Milky Way,
and it's enveloped
in a halo of dark matter,
represented here by a blue gas.
We believe that every single galaxy,
or almost every single galaxy,
lives inside of a dark matter halo.
And we think that they're not alone.
The Milky Way itself has around 60
gravitationally bound satellite galaxies
that are in its orbit.
Some of these, you may have seen
when observing the night sky,
or you may have heard of,
like the Large Magellanic Cloud
and the Small Magellanic Cloud.
Each of these satellites
lives inside of its own
dark matter subhalo.
So, like the invisible enby
in their suit,
the presence of dark matter
is affecting how galaxies are distributed
throughout space-time.
So we can also reverse-engineer
where dark matter is --
it's represented here
by the bluish purple.
We can look at how images
of galaxy clusters
are distorted, which tells us something
about how dark matter
is distorting space-time.
So we know something
about how much dark matter there is,
and even how the dark matter
is distributed,
but what kind of particle is it?
So all that we know
is that it's beyond
standard-model physics.
It's not like any of the particles
that we have ever seen
or had any kind of contact with.
Alright, so this seems
like a potentially terrifying,
intractable problem,
because we're talking
about something that we can't see,
something that we can't touch.
You might be thinking,
"OK, they haven't had many ideas
about that over the years,
because that just seems really hard."
Right?
So here's the Venn diagram
to end all Venn diagrams.
(Laughter)
[Theories of Dark Matter]
So I'll bet y'all a hundred dollars
that you can't find a better one.
At least according to me.
(Laughter)
So Tim Tait created this diagram
to help us visualize
just some of the hypotheses
that physicists have had over the years
to explain the dark matter problem
and how these ideas
overlap with each other.
So as you all can see,
there's a lot happening here, right?
And hopefully, it's becoming
increasingly clear
that this isn't
just an astrophysics problem
of galaxies and galaxy clusters,
but this is also
a particle physics problem.
In order to understand
what's happening on the largest scales,
we need to understand
something very small,
like a new particle,
or maybe primordial black holes.
So you've been looking
at this for a moment,
and you know what you're all
really thinking is,
"What's Chanda's favorite
dark matter candidate?"
Right? This is what you're dying to know?
So, I'll end the suspense
by telling you ...
that my favorite candidate
is something called the axion.
This is the hypothetical particle.
And the first thing that I want
to tell you about the axion
is that it was almost
called the higglet ...
(Laughter)
And whoever chose "the axion"
just completely blew it, OK?
I'm pretty bummed about that.
But the axion is a compelling particle,
because it's a twofer:
it addresses a problem
that we already had,
a conflict between theory and experiment
in the realm of quark physics.
"OK," you say, "but, like,
how can I visualize it?"
At this point in the talk,
you should know better, right?
Because to first approximation,
dark matter is invisible.
(Laughter)
But I know you really want a visual,
so I'm going to give you one.
Here's what it looks like to me,
in my everyday work.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Which is to say,
it's OK if this is unintuitive.
(Laughter)
The universe is a wonderfully strange
and fantastical place,
and that's why humans as a species
have always wanted to study it.
And this is why we have so much fun,
trying to understand it.
So how are we going to go
looking for the axion
or any other dark matter particle?
You might think that we have to use
traditional particle physics approaches,
like colliders, where we smash
particles together
and see what comes out.
But astrophysical signals
have something to say.
Telescopes from across
the electromagnetic spectrum --
for example, the proposed NASA facility,
the STROBE-X X-ray space telescope --
can help us potentially determine
what exactly dark matter is.
But telescopes look at the very large.
How can we use the extremely large
to understand something so small?
Well, in the case of the axion,
it helps to pay attention
to its quantum classification.
So all particles come
in one of two quantum categories,
fermions and bosons.
So fermions, even when things get cold,
like to keep their distance
from each other.
They're antisocial.
That's how it is.
Bosons, on the other hand,
when they get below
a critical temperature,
they're like five-year-olds
on a soccer field,
so they don't have a concept of formation,
they just bunch up together.
So in technical terms,
we call this the formation
of a Bose-Einstein condensate,
where all the particles come together
and act like one superparticle.
So importantly, axions are bosons,
and so now you have a sense
of why I like working with them.
I'm completely enamored with the idea
of axion Bose-Einstein condensates.
So usually, we talk about creating
these quantum states in the lab,
using atoms,
but now,
we're talking about the possibility
of new, maybe galaxy-scale
Bose-Einstein condensates
made out of dark matter.
So what you're looking at here
is a simulation developed
by a team that I lead.
It's an axion condensate
orbiting a central mass.
So it's like a subhalo
orbiting its host galaxy.
Maybe the Large Magellanic Cloud
orbiting the Milky Way.
As you can see,
over the age of the universe,
the subhalo starts
to get to get torn apart,
and what my team's work shows
is that the way
that this happens with axions
is different than with other
dark matter candidates,
because it goes into this special
condensate state.
Now imagine the possibility
that there's more than one type
of dark matter candidate.
Maybe there's more than one type
of dark matter particle?
How much richer this picture can be.
There's no cosmic rule that says
there can only be one.
So in the end,
I expect the universe to force us
to reevaluate what we thought we knew.
[Making the invisible visible.]
When we honor the land and the sky ...
as our galactic relations ...
and their Indigenous stewards,
it becomes possible for us to imagine
new ways of being
in good relations with each other.
That's why I, as a Black queer person,
am so proud to follow
in the footsteps of my ancestors,
who studied and dreamed
with the night sky,
sometimes of freedom.
Astronomers like Harriet Tubman,
for whom the recently launched
James Webb Space Telescope
should be renamed.
(Applause)
I honor the gay NASA employees
who were persecuted
under the leadership of JWST's namesake,
even as I share in the tremendous
community-wide excitement
for what that facility
is going to teach us about dark matter.
And I honor the memory of Vera C. Rubin,
the astronomer who first asked me,
as a young, terrified graduate student,
"How do you think we should solve
the dark matter problem?"
We live in an amazing time
to be doing dark matter research.
Over the next decade,
we're going to see the universe
with incredible accuracy and clarity
thanks to these new telescopes
on the ground and in the sky.
We'll probably get some answers,
but we're going to get
a host of new questions.
And my team? We're going to be ready.
So the search for dark matter is on.
What's your favorite candidate?
(Laughter)
If it's not an axion, you better fix that.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)